great stories can change your life great
stories with great scores will blow your
mind I see you will there's nothing like
the right music at the right place right
time back me up bill I will back you up
on that bar score music music is a
language that speaks straight to our
souls we feel it we love it and we're
grateful for the geniuses who do it
right here are the nominees for Best
Original Score
Filomena by Alex on this plot / by
William Butler and Owen Pallett saving
mr. banks by Thomas Noonan
The Book Thief by John Williams gravity
by Steven price Steven price gravity
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you Academy thank you so
very much
Alfonso I share this with you you
inspired every frame of this film and
certainly every note that I ever wrote
thank you for this remarkable
opportunity and to all the musicians and
friends who lend their talents to this
score
thank you I get to stand here but this
really longs to all of us thank you to
all at Warner Brothers thank you to GSA
everyone in this film for the incredible
support one of the amazing things about
working on this film is that in telling
the story of Ryan stone we've got to
ultimately bring her home and celebrate
life and this is dedicated to people
with whom I share my life my family
thank you mum dad Jenny sorry I made so
much noise when I was growing up my wife
Gemma are lovely children a me neither
thank you so much
[Applause]